Linus, wake up,
I'm going to throw a party.
Everyone should dress up.
And at midnight I want someone to sing that
New Year's song that people always sing.
Auld Lang Syne?
That's the one.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one...
happy New Year!
(song) Should auld acquaintance be forgot
and never brought to mind?
Should auld acquaintance be forgot
and days of auld lang syne?
For auld lang syne, my dear
For auld lang syne
We'll take a cup of kindness yet
Should auld acquaintance be forgot
and never brought to mind?
and days of auld lang syne?
For auld lang syne, my dear
For auld lang syne
We'll take a cup of kindness yet
For auld lang syne, my dear
For auld lang syne
- Happy New Year Lucy.
- Happy New Year Charlie Brown.
(Song) We'll take a cup of kindness yet
For auld lang syne